we have the story about you you probably
have seen it these two it's like two or
three cops they're standing his old guy
walks up they like push him the guy
stumbles backwards falls hit Assad
believes from his ear and he's in
serious condition and this led to a huge
outcry now I personally don't like the
video and I complained about it because
I think whatever your argument is we
can't have like look all these cops what
did whatever they're doing you've got to
be able to in the moment say this guy is
an old guy who's whether he's angry or
not and you've got to be able to adapt
if an old man comes up to you and he's
going wrong look imagine if Joe Biden
walked up to you and was all belligerent
oh I would push him immediately no
hesitation I didn't say he was sniffing
your sister Oh walks up to you you said
I won't expect him he would probably see
my long hair you can't see my long hair
right now but I'd be like whoa whoa whoa
Biden back off he come up behind you now
dude he did certain brushing my hair he
does that he like anyway the point is if
an old man walks up to you I understand
there's there's difficult circumstances
but when you look around here look man
I've been in these situations with cops
mm-hmm I do not believe any of this was
necessary but I got it I gotta admit it
does look like it was an accident
but it's big I think it's rooted in them
not really not being trained properly
and not thinking as individuals I really
do feel that way yeah and I and the
reason I say that is not to be
disrespectful
it's just when this guy falls over he's
bleeding one of the guys actually stops
like like he looks like didn't help him
and the other cop like pushes him on the
back like now go forward yeah saw him
and then he calls it in mm-hm and so I
think they realize like oh man this guy
felt like what do I do and no no no
ignore them like we'll take care of it
and that's all you can do it shouldn't
have happened in the first place true
you can't you I think we can't have
policing that treats every single
situation as though it's gonna be
rioters yeah because then you actually
make riots but that's how they're
trained isn't it like aren't they
trained to to be able to handle the
worst of the worst situations and always
expect that that could happen I don't
because the truth of the matter is
though that is a that could happen right
like they could a situation can turn
seemingly normal to someone shooting at
them
you know write that quickly you know so
man it's a tough situation
you know man I've been in situations
like this I've been surrounded by
antiphon you got to keep your cool yeah
so I think one of the challenges not so
much the training but the directives
they have like you can't do this you
have to do this and so that create a
specific example what do you mean
so like stay in formation don't break
ranks no matter what okay
so when they when the guy falls over in
the one cop like you know kind of
reaches down and then the other cops
like no no no no you like it looks like
he like puts him on the back like to
keep going yeah well it looked like the
cop wanted to check if he was all right
I was like oh so a spark of humanity oh
he wanted to see if he was okay but the
guy behind him nope were we would be
enjoyable or like what was going through
his head there you know I think there's
there's something I refer to as a
scaling problem okay and and I know many
of you listen my videos you probably
already have heard me say it but I think
I'm gonna repeat it for anybody who
doesn't know it if a Apple gives out a
hundred iPhones and 1% break right then
everyone's like well what I don't know
is one phone cares if they give it out
if they give out a hundred million
phones and 1% break now you've got a
million stories popping up yeah
so I think that's what's happening with
a lot of big city police departments for
the most part you have normal encounters
but you have a margin of error I do
think the margin of failure for police
increases as the communities become more
disparate and and Frank well and when
you when you think about how people are
finding about to add your example like
the people finding out about these
broken iPhones who's telling everybody
about these broken iPhones yeah in right
so in funny but in the inverse though we
got the mainstream media controlling
what people are seeing right so they're
amplifying it and any little tiny thing
that they know what to spark the fire
that's already blazing hovering you
don't really bothers me what I was I
can't member what city I was in but
there was a big group of older black
people chanting all lives matter
okay and I live streamed it the median
you can't find it man I searched for it
I'm like where can I find this was
Cincinnati I couldn't find it mom pretty
sure was Cincinnati and it was older
black people chanting all lives matter
and then I started to think like I you
know what
seeing with this identitarian identity
rien ism stuff isn't about race about
age young people are intersectional list
racialist s-- ethnicity ever in a column
left us identitarian and the older crowd
isn't yeah that's why you know in my
experience the older crowd hasn't been
with a dash of entitlement yeah in the
younger people for the younger
generation oh yeah man heaven forbid
they ever use their hands that's work
we're so spoiled like i'm I admit it
fully I'm spoiled I lied man I can go to
I'm a vegan I can go to the store and
get meat that is vegan made from plants
it's amazing like what time we're at you
know
so at running water clean water even
simple being able to flush the toilet
and let my my poop get carried away like
that's incredible what a time we're in
right now we don't think about the fact
that we didn't normally have these kind
of things for what 99.99% of the human
civilization I tell you the occupy farm
story what oh yeah I think you did but
ghosts were granted farmland and it was
like a couple acres and they were like
come upstate and here's some farmland
for the activists and a bunch of people
did yeah they wanted to get off the grid
and go green and just live sustainably
how long do you think they lasted day
two weeks two weeks that's longer than I
would have expected stalking my friend
yeah go and I was like why only two
weeks and she told me she's like because
you wake up at 6 a.m. and go to bed at
midnight you have to work all day until
bed yep and I was like and I was like
yeah and what we taught you so yeah I do
that now right she was like mmm I wanted
to just chill in my apartment like read
and stuff
on my home so you like the comforts well
so let's let's read about why these
officers are resigning yeah they say 57
officers have resigned from their
positions on a buffalo police squad in
support of two colleagues who were
suspended after they were filmed shoving
a 75 year old peace activists to the
ground causing him to crack open his
head the two officers were suspended
without pay and are now under criminal
investigation after footage showed them
knocking Martin Gugino to the ground and
leaving him with critical injuries in
front of Buffalo City Hall in upstate
New York on Thursday night the Buffalo
Police Benevolent Association told the
investigative post that all members of
the department in departments emergency
response team have since resigned good
I'm happy about it I am so happy about
it you know why no tell me give the
people what they want man
this is what I can't you know I get it
when it comes to New York City and the
police are between a rock and a hard
place where if they actually stop the
looters and there's police brutality
videos and if they don't and the
residents complain I'll tell you what
men if the residents of these cities
want you out but they're unwilling to
actually stand up and call for it to
support you then stop I'll tell you what
you see right now you see a bunch of
activists showing up in your town saying
abolish the police and then all the
residents are minding their own business
saying oh well okay then here's the vote
you've got 17 destroy the you know
abolish the police and you know four
hundred sixty-three thousand no vote
abstained guess who wins so if the
police aren't getting the support they
need and the smartest thing they can do
in my opinion is resign if the residents
don't want to stand up for the cops
because the cops are bad well then there
you go the cops can resign and if they
mean is shoving it down everyone's
throat that all cops are bad now I mean
we see cops are getting attacked
yeah cop doesn't matter what race you
are oh man that video is brutal I don't
think I can play it no I can play a
little bit maybe but I think because
they use racial slurs okay sound off so
I mean it's you don't even need to you
can see it all this is you can really
you can you cannot you can tell
obviously what's happening you got a
black cop it even looks like a little
older and they they actually start
attacking them you know what do you what
do you call it when a group of angry
white people attack a black man I know I
guess that's when they kill them that's
a step further it's racially targeted no
they're mean they're there it's it's
racist yeah it's like is it there are
they just saying it because he's a cop
or you know it's like they're out
marching for black lives matter and then
you start attacking a black cop like
that doesn't cause it makes sense
because that phrase doesn't mean
anything to them
yep it's a mindless mantra I don't
actually care is what I tell my friends
man I'm like you got to realize these
people who are going out don't care
about this and that's why I don't like
them because when they say to me things
like we're fighting for people of color
I say oh okay let me tell you about my
experience they go well you're white
you're not you're not color enough no no
my us the scale that my colored is
dependent upon how much I agree with
them right and that's the way I'm like
you know care about what I think you
don't care about helping me or my family
or anything like that you're just lying
because you know it's it's really really
simple man this country is like 70 72
percent white or summer to you know some
large number and so they'd they're not
trying to win over the non-white
demographic they're trying to win over
the white demographic it's it's it's
listen when you're a company you have
two choices right I mean I just bear
with me you can make a sparrow guess
flavored ice cream or chocolate favorite
ice cream okay now how many people do
you think like asparagus flavored ice
cream zero 0.0001 maybe right over
talking percents yeah sure how many
people like chocolate ice cream sixty
sixty five percent of the popular over
chocolate I'm not I didn't say no no no
I did today they didn't like vanilla I'm
saying just that they like chocolate Oh
last thing is your mom all right no
increase okay so if you're gonna start a
company that sells ice cream are you
gonna choose to make asparagus flavored
ice cream no that's stupid you're gonna
make whatever panders to the biggest
crowd so when you see these people
that's why all of these people out
protesting for black lives matter are
white they're chanting to convince white
people they're noble they want the white
leftists to feel good about themselves
meanwhile what did you see how many
videos of minorities have we seen
complaining about this how many rappers
like high-profile rappers have been like
dude what are you doing destroying our
business yeah and then the white
liberals and media go you don't
understand
they're just traumatized and he's like
what I live here they burned down my
store and you're like you don't get it
because you're a bigot I'm seeing all
these videos all day long all it is is
just these these members of their
community
what are you guys doing this is
ridiculous this is them trying to
control all of you each video and watch
ins like that's the Wow no you know the
powerful truth right there
you know I say clearly don't care about
the movement the the peaceful protesters
are all black holding up signs
protesting peacefully it's like legit
and then there are looters and then
there's looters that everybody do it
they don't care about that
exactly and there are all sorts of I've
seen all races lewd lewd people looting
here's the problem here's brown men they
don't care the ideological looting and
attacks are like the white auntie Fudd
but then a lot of the looting videos you
see or black people doing it okay I'm
not saying that it's it's more of one or
the other I'm not saying that I'm saying
those things going around yeah I was
talking my friend about this and I said
she my friend was telling me that she
knows like overt racists down south that
are sharing all these videos thanks see
see see it proves it and I'm like this
is a big problem that these white
leftists support this because it's fuel
for racism yeah seriously if you only
show you know I I don't I don't know I
don't know what the actual makeup is for
these videos in the race or anything
like that okay all I know is a lot of
the videos that are going around show
one race doing it and then you'll see
racists being like see and I'm like man
there's so much more than that and
that's that's that's what I can't stand
about these people because when we were
when we were talking about this in the
very beginning about privilege yeah it's
it's they think if you're born with nope
with with no privilege it's harder for
you to succeed and if you have privilege
it's easier to succeed that way you must
check that's why you must check your
privilege it's like okay so it's a class
argument yeah exactly Will Smith's kids
grew up way more advantage than both of
us probably you know it's funny Alexis
Ohanian
you know he is no co-founder I've read
it okay he just resigned from the board
right and he said he wants his position
be filled by a black person okay and
he's gonna give all future gain uh gains
from his I guess stock or whatever to
invest in the black community and stuff
like that okay
he's married to Serena I think he's
married Serena Williams and he has a
daughter with her and it's like bro you
so he doesn't white any of that he's
already achieved it and it's like sure
whatever what
what what is your wife worth in terms of
millions of dollars she's not a pressed
dude like I understand there are some
things that can be oppressive yeah but
on the whole man your family has so much
power now Alexis oh really
he's a really nice guy I'm not trying to
suspect him I know I mean he's always
been super super cool he's very very
diplomatic and he's and he's a really
nice guy so and I got respect from
trying to do good I just think first of
all if that's what he wanted to do I got
no beef go ahead and do it I just think
that's a misguided attempt it look if
you're gonna help anybody that's cool
I don't care who he gives the money to
to help teach learn educational centers
yeah I just see this as you know someone
who has grown up in on the south side to
a mixed family the I've seen white
people suffer with no privilege thrown
in the gutter arrested falsely all these
things you know it's just about look if
you think that my marginalized
communities black people brown people
Hispanic Asian whatever are worse off to
start because of wealth then if you
approach this from a class angle then
you deal with it all and you don't got
to worry about singling anybody out did
a race yeah you want to know what I just
found out what's really interesting so
Serena Williams is worth 200 million
dollars Alexis Ohanian is worth hello
seventy million dollars more than twice
what her husband is worth and he's
giving all so they're married so that's
yeah 70 mil together hold on hold on so
so so far this they have successfully
smashed the white heteronormative no
it's just the white patriarchy right and
the glass ceiling for her yeah just the
white patriarchy yeah so there's still
these heteronormative aspect they
haven't been able to deal with right
right they did have a client Alexis he
has he's no he's gonna have to go
gender-neutral or something no no I mean
I don't mean to disrespect of them
because I think Serena is actually super
cool she's an amazing athlete I think
alexis is it's weird I've bumped into
Alexis in like really weird situations
like randomly at the airport one day I'm
like Alexis and he's like oh hey man how
you doing he's a he's a really good dude
and this I see what he's doing and I I
want to I want to make sure this is very
clear what he's doing is cool you
he's not right on anybody he's not
coming down on anybody that's what I
don't like he's literally saying I'm
gonna give up some of what I have to try
and help others right that's right on
it's great my only thing is I wish
people were more focused on class issues
agreed a hundred percent agreed yeah
because if like I was just saying if you
think it is mostly about race then
you'll still end up mostly helping that
race by your own logic you can just
avoid the all lives matter black lives
matter argument outright yeah and bring
people together by saying we're help
everybody who's poor right and and guess
what you can even say weird however
everybody's poor on the southside of
Chicago and I guess what you end up
wrapping up Latinos you get you get
black people involved and you're helping
creating an education center that can
bring everyone together yeah not only
that what I think we really need to
especially in Chicago cuz we talked
abouts the other day would be like some
kind of community center bridging these
these racial lines where they separate
different communities awesome sounds
great yeah because then you'll have
people of all races hanging out yeah
it's like playing card games skateboard
and everything it always happens it's
like whenever you know the a guy who
went to all these different white
nationalists and was talking to him and
converting them Darrell Darrell Davis
Darrell Davis awesome dude
but what what he was doing was proving
to them that we're all the same oh you
like the same thing as me we have been
cars all of a sudden something clicked
it's like oh wow I didn't even think
that you could be the same as me yeah I
I refuse to let all this thing's all
these things that are going on today
create that divide and that's what's
happening it's like someone out there
wants us to be divided and we need to
just stop that we got to realize we're
all dude we're all in this together or
there's an asteroid right now that's
flying towards Earth I'm not joking I
know it's it's if it hits us we could
all just die that could happen boom and
we wouldn't be able to stop it yeah or
we could just come together I mean yeah
obviously it's not gonna hit us it's
actually gonna be like 60 million miles
oh don't don't don't come on man we're
going to be optimistic here we don't
know I'm not it's not gonna hit us I'm
saying no I know I I know yeah don't say
don't you're taking my people's hope
right now
somebody tweeted a now somebody tweeted
the story of the meteor head turrets and
they were like thank you know like
finally come on finally it's the waiting
I can't stand right seriously I love
everybody we got it we got to realize
we're all in this together you know what
you know when I was a little s when I
was little I used to hang out with we
had you know there was a Mexican kid
there's a Filipino kid and I was
thinking about about this when I was
growing up some bunch of white people
and I was just like whenever I would
hear about racism and stuff I thought to
myself I really think proximity is gonna
end all this because a lot of the racism
stuff you hear comes from isolated
communities people who have never met a
person of a certain race can only
imagine based on stereotypes they've
seen in TV or movies or whatever yeah
and so I was really excited I was like I
think when were like the more we spend
time together and over time it'll heal
these wounds and then when we're older
you know like in a few generations we're
gonna be like oh yeah that's you know
that's John from down the street and it
might be an Asian person or a black
person and that was when Occupy Wall
Street happened they were intent on
segregating everybody they they really
did this you know directed by Wall
Street they created racial groups and
made sure everybody stayed in their
group and they wouldn't allow people to
cross over that's it yeah
so if you wanted to vote for resources
you had racial blocks yeah so like all
the black people part of a caucus all
the white people oh no that there was no
white people caucus you weren't allowed
to the Asia
the Asians Latino the women's it was
only for marginalized groups and so what
do you think happens then when you have
only people based on race separate from
each other fighting for resources it
creates a divide talk about it creates
segregation it's like we got to realize
that it's a class issue all of society
needs to be revamped so that everyone
can benefit and that's not the way it is
you know you know it is a class issue
but you know what else it is it's and I
don't know what causes it but young
people are really unworldly right okay
they don't like we were just talking
about it they don't understand the value
of hard work that's true you're right
and they like they there's a boil that
we're entitled what were we saying
earlier like we are we are cooking
earlier john d rockefeller would look
upon the homeless
of America today with envy yeah this guy
hundred years ago richest guy in the
world oil baron yeah
laughing with his monocle I control the
world energy then he would look into the
future and see a homeless guy walking to
a McDonald's with air conditioned air
conditioning with clean Quintron clean
running water
he'd walk into an urgent clinic and give
two bucks for an antibiotic and he'd be
like wow
not only that he'd see the homeless guy
and be like this homeless man has no
polio and they'd be like yeah no one
does it's cured he'd be like what Wow
harumph Wow no be shy it would be envy
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you